alright welcome everybody to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
with Erica erica is the founder of madly
juicy which s an online resource for
Millennials and has over 10,000
subscribers and she asked me to come on
and talk about success for Millennials
and how they can get their side hustle
on part time entrepreneurs while it's
doing other things too and that's it
Erica welcome aboard thank you thank you
so much for us so exited to this entire
so for the top 10 rules yes we did my
top 10 rules for success for for
Millennials doing a side hustle I
haven't done my own top 10 rules for
success video my audience actually put
one together for me a while ago so I
thought it'd be fun to involve the live
audience now again to have them help me
pick the top 10 rules things and i would
say because they've heard me so much to
help millennial entrepreneurs i'll do
the first one though for me the first
one's always follow your passion and you
have to do the thing that you are
excited about that gets you motivated
that when you wake up in the morning it
kind of gets you through a lot of people
especially when you're to start the
part-time business if you've got other
things school going on you know
relationships that you're trying to
figure out it's easy to lose track of
your time it's easy to get pulled in a
thousand different directions and so
it's it's hard to find the time to work
on your business and a thing that gets
you through that is the mad insane
passion for what you're doing when it
looks like it's not going to work out
you would do it anyway because you're
not just chasing a result you enjoy the
process so like if you wanted to start
an online magazine if you're just trying
to get a million subscriber just you
know to come to your channel uh that's
not going to drive you in the long run
where if you generally enjoy doing
interviews and creating content then
it'll make a big difference so it's
really having a passion for the work
that you're doing and not just be
attached to the outcome that you look
for that's my number one all right it
does make a lot of sense so let's turn
to the live audience and see what do you
guys think leaving the chat let me know
you think my top 10 rules would be for
Millennials who want to start a side
business uh so coming in your
environment that's a good one have any
way so what I would say is like have an
environment an environment for greatness
uh I believe it's hard to do something
great in let's who surrounded by
greatness it speaks to my environment
here and all the people behind me are
here for a reason but what is good I'm
sorry but what do you think you know
like they are so many people who
actually working on my room there what
kind of difficult you know so what do
you think about them because it doesn't
necessarily apply to their situation you
know yeah so you you have an environment
that you are forced into right like your
parents your school you know and your
parents may hate the idea of you being
an entrepreneur they me you may don't
even know your parents you know their
abilities situations but you can still
design like where are you working like
where are you getting your business on
right now is it in your your apartment
or in your you know parents house in
your bedroom right like what's on the
walls it matters what kind of content
are you consuming right are you are you
you know reading madly juicy Maddy juice
madly juicy yes like filling your head
with knowledge right are you watching
videos and books and reading books that
kind of make you be the best version of
yourself you know not everybody is born
into the good fortune of having you know
parents and family to support what
they're doing and teach them how to do
well although that means send a lot of
people who have all the things set up
for them they don't they don't do it
like there's so many businesses that the
founder built it up and then they handed
off to their kids and their kids run it
into the ground and the kids had all the
education all the upbringing and all the
mentorship and all the access to
resources and they let the company burn
and so it's not about the resources is
about the results resourcefulness that
might be another point that piece of his
I'm gonna write that down number three I
would say not about the resources it's
about the resort's full this so applying
that to your environment that's thinking
about your habits your morning routine
who you surround yourself with what
books you're reading all of that stuff
there's a lot that you can't control you
know you can't control your parents are
that that's done fit that boat has
sailed but you can control again what
look when you load up your computer or
when you load up your phone what's the
background image you know one of the
main apps that you're looking at every
day are you just wasting time on an app
that is not contributed to you achieving
your goal or you're trying to fill your
head with knowledge and resources to
help you be the best version of you so
I'm writing them down as we go I'm gonna
get to 10 all the impatient have an
environment for greatness so if you want
to do great things you have to be
surrounded by greatness and number three
it's not about the resources is both the
resourceful this okay all right we got
three guys we had three what's next add
more value add more value um it is true
uh one of the things I like to talk
about is making money is about providing
value maybe we'll do that making money
is about providing value where a lot of
people want to like to have this go I
want to be a millionaire I want to make
a ton of money where if you want to make
money that you need provide value and
help somebody that's that's business
right if you know if madly Juicy's
creating insane great content a lot more
people going to come and marriage isn't
going to make a lot more money for
people who are doing their side hustle
you need to figure out in the limited
time that you have what's the most value
that you can give to somebody else's
life can you help them solve a problem
have you solved the problem in your own
life that others would be really
fascinated by and be willing to pay you
for it as well if you want to make a lot
of money quickly the Nene provide a lot
of value
quickly that's how it is that's like a
principle of business it comes down to
if you want a sustainable business not
about ripping people off right it's not
about promising something i'm going to
give you all this value and then you
don't deliver on it right that might get
you a quick paycheck but you're
constantly going to be worried that that
verse is like banging down your door
saying hey you didn't you didn't fulfill
your promise well we want you we want to
be around for a long time we want to
maybe turn that side hustle to our
full-time business and then eventually
be able to hire people and build and
grow so it all comes down to be no
provide value to your clients okay I
love it that's number four all right
come on keep it coming guys it's number
five buh-buh-buh-buh when we got what we
got when we got follow your passion we
did that one small decisions without is
a good one yeah small decisions with the
head big ones with the heart a lot of
people when they're starting to business
so trying to figure out their side
hustle try to do the logical thing try
to look at they open up a copy of ink
magazine it's like the hundred fastest
growing companies in the world hottest
industries right now is I'm gonna go do
that because I can make a lot of money
where if you're not into it then you're
not going to have success no matter how
much other people are having success and
so sometimes they had in the harder
alarm then in that case it's super easy
to make a decision but in big decisions
I believe we need to trust your heart
and not your head because the head only
knows a world that exists and is
practical where the heart can help you
create a new world that doesn't yet
exist and so I think back to my example
when I was a struggling entrepreneur in
university 19 years old had my first
company I apologize was definitely got
these crazy alibis happy right now 19
years old struggling company make a few
hundred dollars a month and get these
opportunities to go make you know
six-figure starting salary at the dream
job I thought I always wanted and
something kept me back to say I don't
I don't want to go work at that big
company I want to do my own thing but
like the safe logical smart practical
thing to do is to go take that job and
that's what the head says to do that's
what your friends may tell you do you're
failing say to do but something inside
me felt like I would regret this if I
didn't at least try with my own company
to make it last a little bit longer and
see what i could do with it and so just
like when you're deciding to marry
somebody or get into a relationship it's
from the heart like the heart has to be
there it's not about oh well on paper
this person has these skills and counts
of this family and that i right that's
how you marry somebody comes from
someone that you actually love and so
all the big decisions in your life I
don't believe come from just making a
list and comparing but from going with
the one that feels right for you that is
coming from the heart that you have that
emotional attachment to and then the
small things are done with the head the
small things like once you have that
plan once you know what you want to do
your head will help you figure out how
to go and made that happen so big this
is with the heart swells with the head
okay makes sense I like that one that
was a good one okay we got this that's
five keeping common guys if we got maybe
build your business around your values
not your products you don't box yourself
in that's not bad build around your
values so the idea here is a most people
when they're learning to sell learn the
cell based off the features of what they
offer right so you know i'm i'm the
classic as i'm selling a nail right like
this is a nail and it's silver and it's
three inches long or whatever we're
somewhere along the lines you turn about
you learn about course selling ice are
you learning about selling the the
benefits where people don't want the
nail they want to hang something on the
wall and so you're talking about that
where you move up the step you get into
core selling and course hell is much
more about selling values and people
want to know what your company
stands for before the care about
anything else and there are some
companies that we all know and love that
that you will go and shop for and spend
more money at because of what they stand
for is a company so you look at Whole
Foods people go to Whole Foods the price
is higher like you're not going to
hopefully get cheap anything even a
stuff on sale is not cheap at whole
foods but you're going because you're
assuming that everything there is
healthy least healthier than going to a
walmart or a you know grocery store and
so because you know that it's healthy
you're going to go shop there or the
honest company i'm christopher gavigan
the founder the honest country and
earlier today multi-billion dollar
valuation everything that they make
you're assuming is non-toxic is healthy
for your body and so you pay a premium
for that where if you walk into a costco
you know you look at the ingredients
what's in this thing and you're making
sure that it doesn't have any that you
know- ingredients that you're looking
for but when you go to Whole Foods
you're not checking the ingredients as
much because we just assume when
everything is healthy so people want to
know what you stand for and that your
values are aligned and if they can
understand that then they're much more
likely to buy from you then the next guy
so an example I use is look into the guy
cut in the grass and this is important
right like side hustle might be mowing
lawns in the summer now or shovel in the
driveway in the winter when it comes up
for Millennials you don't want to be
beaten down on price if people can't
tell the difference between what you do
and what somebody else does then it just
going to beat you down on price like
well why am I going to pay you thirty
bucks to cut my lawn when the guy next
door's gonna do it for 15 and so the
answer comes down to the values and so I
had a caller to my radio show Colin and
I asked him why did he start this lawn
mowing business and he said I when I was
working in the garden when I was young
it was always with my mom and I got the
passion for gardening and taking care of
grass from my mom and I treat
every log that I cut like it's my mom's
lot and right there it's like you feel
the pride you feel the passion to feel
the joy that comes from that compared to
somebody's just trying to make a buck
like I would pay more for that I would
pay more to know that my grass is being
cut with care precision like he was cut
in his own mom's launch that's worth
thirty bucks instead of 15 bucks I mean
but if you don't express that then
you're constantly going to be beaten
down on price so it comes down to
branding I guess the way somebody sell
himself or herself yeah Brandon is one
extension of it the first part is
understanding why you're doing this
business like understanding who you are
as human being what your your one word
is what your most important value is to
you and then expressing that so you know
mine is about believe I believe in
entrepreneurs all the videos that I put
out how people believe in themselves and
believe in others so that helps me in
the marketing on the percent people who
want more believe in their life they
come back to the YouTube channel on a
consistent basis but it also helps me
hire the right people it also helps to
attract media attention it also helps me
make operating decisions you know if I
could get a really great editor who
could put up amazing videos for me but
didn't like what we were doing the guys
just another job I don't want that
person like I want the person who
believes in the mission and what we're
all about it has that same core value as
me or at least something similar because
they're gonna I don't want just their
their minds I want their soul I want the
hearts and soul to be attached to the
cause of what we're all about and so a
lot of people don't even know what they
stand for let alone express it so
Brandon is one expression of that value
that you have you want to tell the world
what you're all about so that that'll
attract customers and media and exposure
to you but it's also how you run the
business how you hire people to your
team how you create the processes
internally to run the company may not be
super important yet as Millennials like
I'm just decide I'm doing it myself yeah
hot stone right like I don't have a team
but having a self-awareness understand
what you staying for so that when you're
faced with challenging opportunities to
say yes or no to that decision being
able to connect with people who share
the same values as you do so you don't
spend too much time going down the wrong
path of the people who don't share the
same values just like getting married
like they could look great on paper but
if they don't like if you don't believe
in the same thing you're just going to
be fighting all the time and it won't be
a great marriage so you if you don't
have the same values as your customers
or your partners or suppliers or your
investors or you know the people around
you it's not going to be a great
situation so you want to make sure
you're building around your values
that's six guys keep it coming we got uh
another chatting you guys are chatting
you guys are chatting give me some rules
give me some rules you get creative
ideas from your business in the shower
Rishi really mean value here I think I
love sure enough
okay i don't know if it's only on my
side but i cannot i mean it doesn't work
anymore yeah the image is tech ok not
working
you
you
you